welcome to this video playing Zeke Motta
from Turkey and the English Defence yet
again and okay it's played a very solid
set up not so ambitious but very well
founded of course not home he loves me
to take this is slightly surprising I
wouldn't have allowed that I think yeah
I mean chess must be really an easy game
if you can play every move in two
seconds even if you have five minutes
available better play a 4 instantly now
why it is already in trouble threatening
a form and have a very very good
structure let's see 97 96 mmm or a 5 now
maybe 85 just block this entirely yeah
okay every move needs to be play
instantly yeah black it just just a pawn
up here
really don't see any any compensation ok
so we form on or something else queen g5
it's not completely pointless yeah but
probably just this morning check
97 96 are used for strengthening moves
can old song yeah I was thinking maybe
even Luke f6 Luke h6 some size and
summer tech but this is probably not not
very realistic
yeah I'd like to keep this strong point
on on the only form for the time being
okay if I take you can take with the
night but I have Queen Queen to e5 for
example yeah one possible idea can also
take here night at five Queenie fibers
this is probably probably the easiest
okay and so 95 possible and and go into
g5 maybe yeah it's not okay how to
choose many lines that are looking good
but term two to play the most precise
one so it's not so easy okay if it takes
what do I play I mean there's more than
one good move Quincy five Queen g5 check
93 and I'm not so sure what what to do
after that night takes III then this is
a self pin but maybe it's it's still
good with rupee a turn probably that's
just slow good
yeah I try to play quickly not to get in
big time trouble
okay yeah I mean taking is taking one of
three is should be quite good so with
the bishop down on with the rook no
it'll be Sherman hmm this seems easier
and what now if just h 5 4 h 5 h for all
I can also also play Quincy five but
that's not so let's soak not so
convincing maybe just the age five edge
five don't really see what he's doing
against that look they are not even look
III as possible yeah here I have to
check at least I'll go here don't know
okay there's still eight for threatened
and Quincy five check as soon as
possible
so each form on something better okay
let's try to keep ahead on the clock
look here yeah shouldn't be bad to
activate the rook rook to on threatening
your bishop f3 now check Jeremy and
Quincy to made quite resigned yeah I
really don't understand sometimes why
they play so quickly in the opening
because you simply cannot repair this
one second for a four and after that I
don't know it's already I don't like
white anymore and even this see this
year also dashed out very quickly and
like is black is Justin just much better
already you simply you cannot come back
from this if the opponent is playing a
well dear this is just a very bad
position yeah this is even come first
choice of the comp check yeah and it's
gone minus five it's a yeah I was
surprised I mean here he does not need
to allow that he can play move like rook
c1 or something but okay this is
probably not bad but it's not necessary
to to double the pawns and here you have
many ideas and you can
spend some time on it on it look you
want Andy for maybe on yeah maybe here
92 and 84 but this is just losing a move
I mean for for no particular reason and
yeah here already prefer black I mean
it's after 97 I have good control over
c5 and I just have a better central
control and this is already a bit bit
desperate giving hot porn for for not
much yeah SMF it simply does not make
sense to to place so quickly if you
weaken your position so much that you
basically toast after after 15 moves
okay thanks for watching